des commerces et des chaînes de
restaurants chinois fermé des ouvriers
au chômage technique et des habitants
interdits de se déplacer pour éviter
toute propagation du virus
la deuxième puissance économique
mondiale est à l'arrêt résultat la
panique gagne les marchés financiers ce
lundi les bourses de shanghai et de
shenzhen ont plongé de plus de 8%
une chute record depuis 2015 et certains
économistes anticipent déjà une baisse
de la croissance chinoise pour 2020 avec
un pib en baisse de 0,23 point passant à
5 7% en 2020 contre les 6% initialement
attendu mais la chine se veut rassurante
l'économie chinoise est très résistante
et possède un énorme potentiel de
croissance à moyen et long terme
la chine a la capacité et la confiance
nécessaires pour minimiser l'impact
économique de l'épidémie
une épidémie chinoise qui fait
frissonner les économies mondiales des
répercussions économiques se font déjà
sentir dans plusieurs pays de la région
comme à taïwan en cours ou encore en
thaïlande des pays qui exportent
beaucoup de biens et de services
l'europe est elle aussi concernée avec
150 millions de voyages à l'étranger en
2018 selon l'organisation mondiale du
tourisme
l'absence des touristes chinois frappe
de plein fouet l'industrie touristique
au royaume uni le secteur du luxe qui
réalise un tiers de son chiffre
d'affaires auprès de clients chinois
revoit ses perspectives à la baisse
le britannique burberry a par exemple
fermer un tiers de ses 64 magasins en
chine en allemagne
les grandes marques automobiles
allemandes sont en souffrance tout comme
les grandes enseignes de luxe française
mais pas seulement
tous les grands secteurs économiques
sont concernés la chine est le deuxième
fournisseur de la france
il est beaucoup trop tôt pour dresser un
bilan chiffré lorsque la chine qui pèse
un cinquième du pib mondial tourne au
ralenti nous redoutons forcément
d'éventuelles conséquences économiques
pour la france
les partenaires économiques de la chine
espère bien que le premier importateur
et exportateur mondial parviennent à
contenir au plus vite cette crise
sanitaire et ainsi éviter que le
couralin virus ne provoque une crise
économique mondiale
[Musique]